this week conflict zone is in Berlin
where the government has just registered
close to a million asylum seekers this
year alone my guest is piotre
alt Maya who's the refugee coordinator
and the Chancellor's chief of staff has
Germany's open-door policy being for the
country itself and for Europe a colossal
mistake
we got Maya welcome to conflict zone
hello your policies towards migrants and
refugees have brought about exactly the
kind of Europe that you didn't want to
see it's fences its walls its freedom of
movement suspended armed guards on the
borders freedom of movements it's gone
hasn't it it's just what you didn't want
it's a difficult situation I admit but
Europe today is in a better shape then
ten years ago when Angela Merkel was
elected Chancellor in that way anyway
that Europe was able over the last 10
years to decide on concrete issues to
overcome the European sovereign depth
and euro crisis to play a coherent and
convincing role in the Ukrainian crisis
and as far as the refugee crisis is
concerned that is perhaps the biggest
refugee movement Europe has seen over
the last 60 or 70 years the same you
same shape but we've seen Europe at each
other's throats countries in Europe
Financial Times last week we only have
bad options left these are options that
are painful and require breaking taboos
and taking actions that we do not think
tively want to take I entirely I
entirely disagree
Europe has an option to overcome that
refugee crisis and this option is
cooperation this option is coherent
cooperation with Turkey and other
countries in that region and the option
is Bern sharing amongst European
countries the option is organizing a
better asylum and Refugee policy
developing a better protection of the
external borders of the European Union
all these pieces are on the table they
have been put on the table but you can't
say yeah in the beginning we are in the
beginning of a process the this refugee
crisis as far as the current dimension
is concerned was on the table since four
or five months then summer and
and summer we have decided on the on
160,000 refugees that will be sent to
the different member states sent do you
know how about the beginning of this
month how many have been sent a hundred
and fifty nine yes there is something
that is something that is certainly not
acceptable but as you know the decision
was made that these people shall be sent
to the Member States over the next
couple of months
Donald touch the President of the
European Council coded political
coercion that's quite an accusation
towards you from from somebody as senior
as the president I'm dealing you I'm
dealing with I mean I'm dealing with
European politics now for almost twenty
years and I know that it would be a very
bad thing to blame each other in Europe
Germany has ever been part of a solution
not a part of the problem and this is
that means that we are working very hard
on the European turkey agenda on
migration we have achieved the result in
on the European turkey summit two weeks
ago and we will continue theirs and at
the end of the day I'm who have to be
convinced Europe will come to a coherent
common position and were they able to
overcome the crisis you can't even come
to a common position in your own party
and October 30 for regional CDU party
officials complain that the policy of
open borders didn't accord with European
or German law that's very that's very
old-fashioned news and then you look at
the party convention we didn't organize
yes but we have right we have a 500
thousand party activists and out of them
240 have written a letter I believe you
should be honest to the to the people
who on the screens and tell them that we
have as in any other party political
debates there is freedom of expression
any chance you can position but the
Chancellor Merkel enjoys
large the wholehearted support of the
party grassroot of the party convention
of the group in Parliament we have been
able to decide on all the issues by a
very large very you've pushed telling me
have itched been too long and we even
and we have even been able to get a
consensus in the Bundestag in the second
chamber where the opposition of Green
and Social Democratic parties holds a
majority so this is an indication that
Germany challenged by that unprecedented
crisis is able to establish a common
position and we are able to amend our
legislation we are able to deal with the
crisis we are able to accelerate
proceedings for asylum seekers all this
has been organised over the last couple
of months and people are now seeing the
fruits and therefore I'm very optimistic
that Angela Merkel will continue to
ensure support public support not just
by the party but by the people in
Germany polls say two out of three
Germans believe the government is doing
a rather bad or very bad job in handling
the situation this was an eminent poll
taken a month ago it's not much of an
endorsement it's old supposed show that
Angela Merkel's party the CD who is
still leading the polls by far has
dropped its it has dropped from 41 to 39
and the next biggest party the Social
Democrats have still 25 that means we
have a larger lead than any other party
over the last 20 years to two out of
three Germans believe you're doing a
rather bad or a very bad job that's not
a ringing endorsement or an opinion
that's first of all an opinion poll and
second you might not expect people you
won that you don't like you might not
expect people to say oh you are doing a
pretty good job as long as long as the
results are not yet clear and visible to
everybody this was a crisis that
involves several hundred thousand of
people people coming from the Middle
East to Europe and to Germany and it is
of course
a natural thing that this will take some
weeks and month to always my oh this oh
this agreement that you say you've
worked towards we've seen fighting
breaker more than once in your own
cabinet the interior minister Thomas de
mazia twice acted unilaterally to
introduce controls on asylum seekers
without informing mrs. Merkel you called
this a communications issue it's more
than a communication that's exactly what
it was
we have decided all the issues related
to immigration and Asylum by unanimity
in the cabinet meeting and this is a
clear indication that everything else
that you have heard or read has been a
communication problem rather than a
divergence a communications problem from
your own federal office for migration
and refugees which wrote in an open
letter just over a month ago that your
entry procedures are not fit for purpose
so the large proportion of asylum
seekers were giving false identities in
order to stay in Germany discontinuation
of identity checks facilitated
infiltration by Islamic State of Iraq
this is coming from your own federal
office for migration and we have
appointed a president of the office for
Refugees and immigration mr. Weiser who
was the most experienced senior official
in this field he enjoyed the confidence
of Chancellor Merkel and what she's
doing about these issues real issues and
as far as real issues are concerned that
will be solved one after the other
wouldn't it have been nice to actually
warn not only your lender your own
states within Germany but the rest of
Europe that you were going to throw your
doors open and that there were going to
be strong implications severe
implications for the rest of the
continent but you didn't do that you
went your own me to be my size you
wanted to do and you went to the Germans
with German constitution is very clear
with that respect and it says political
refugees enjoy asylum Dreier Palatinate
said you blind
sided us this can never happen again it
should never happen again
your children's are quotes to like you
choose the ones you like I'm choosy I'm
choosing the ones they actually showed a
magician many many there are many prime
ministers of states and others like
mister Kretchman for example who has
wholeheartedly supported Angela Merkel's
policy and Angela Merkel has defended
several times her policy in the European
Council in the German Bundestag in
cabinet meetings and we had to make
difficult choices we had to make
difficult choices when there are tens of
thousands of refugees moving across six
or seven countries they are coming to
the Auslan German border would you then
really think you could stop these people
by forcing them to return do you really
believe it would be a good solution to
to apply to apply the criticism is that
when you wanted to do something out goes
consultation out goes reliability out
goes the consultation with 28 other
countries you did what you wanted and
you left everybody else to pick up there
was a there was indeed there wasn't a
immediate danger at the beginning of
September of it thousands of people of
refugees were on the streets in Hungary
on the railways stations in the trains
and then sequestered north in the
relationship between Austria and Germany
whether it would allow these people to
come to Germany or whether we would try
to stop them Hungary was not able to
stop them no as a country in Europe was
able to stop them neither grace nor
Croatia no Slovenia nor Serbia nor
Hungary nor Astraea and that means we
had to make up our minds and to find the
decision and if he would have tried to
blame other European countries if he
would have tried to return the refugees
to Austria to Hungary or to another
country in the neighbourhood we would
have risked destabilization Europe we
would not have responded to our
humanitarian obligations under the
German constitution and
the Geneva Convention alters President
of the European Council accuses you of
political coercion through your majority
that's a second response this is not my
task and not my duty to to to criticize
or to attack the President of the
European Council but he said you know
you read when you read the interview has
made industry tortured sytem you will
come to the conclusion that he has that
he has black angle a miracle on some of
the points he has also expressed his own
personal use on other points and I think
this must be possible even for a
president of the European count I think
you're putting a nice gloss on this and
I think you're putting a nice gloss on
it and as far that's what I'd expect you
to do but the fact is that he speaks of
huge division over this and not just
from just from Central Europe and
Eastern Europe but other countries that
are not prepared to share in your quota
allocations and relocation plans for the
refugees around you we have we have it
has been a large majority in the council
for relocation of 160,000 people we are
now talking about quotas quotas for
Turkey and at the end of the day you
will see that we are will be able to
agree on a joint concept I have no idea
whether all European countries will join
and especially the new member countries
in Eastern and Central Europe have
difficulties to admit refugees within
their borders
we have always expressed our belief that
this is a crisis that can be solved
together if we want to solve it together
and that everybody should take part in
the burden sharing process and mechanism
we are continuing to do this but we are
not waiting until the last member state
of the European Union has made up his
mind we have a an obligation to act with
the countries where exactly consensus
goes out the window you just pushed when
you remember
oh you know what you want consensus went
out of the window and when during the
second Iraq war in Europe was not able
to to decide on a on its own position
because old Europe was blocking new
Europe and they have been the friends of
the US and the opponents of the u.s.
fighting each other that was a total
blockade where nothing was possible in
this refugee crisis the eu-turkey summit
took place it was able to adopt in
conclusion it was able to adopt a
migration agenda and the fact that we
have debates and that we have some
divisions I admit there is something
natural in such an enormous crisis and
you cannot expect 28 countries to agree
from the beginning on every single step
but we are working in Europe together
all right I hear you I hear you Peter I
am puzzled where this open-door policy
comes from this is the same chancellor
who five years ago declared
multiculturalism had failed in Germany
in October 2010 she told the CDU youth
wing of course the tendency has been to
say let's adopt the multicultural
concept and live happily side-by-side
but this concept has failed that's
exactly it has failed it has failed and
there will be no revival of it takes its
paws the refugees what takes its
hegemony and the ones who will stay for
a longer period that have access to
language training to professional
training so integration yes exactly we
want them to integrate and when you look
at the large population of immigrants
which arrived in Germany after over the
last thirty fourteen years most of them
have been integrated successfully
because it was the last ten years we
have increased our efforts for
integration and we have offered them
possibilities to integrate we have asked
them to integrate and they're successful
is that going to be when you're already
having to make provision to separate gay
refugees from others who have been
harassing them three to six cases a week
of asylum seekers harrassing gay refugee
in Berlin Brandon they came to Germany
to be harvest yeah they wanted to leave
that by Syria may I may I remind you is
not a segregation what we are doing is
to protect vulnerable people there is a
commitment under the Geneva Convention
and our European directives and at the
end of the day we are very optimistic
that a large majority of the young
people coming from Syria from northern
Iraq and other countries in that region
are interested in our culture and our
values and they are interested in our
language and therefore we are optimistic
that we are able to integrate the
backlash from the local population here
already 222 tax and attacks have been
recorded on refugee tracks those attacks
have only four convictions only four
convicted is the procedures are going on
these attacks are awful we they have to
we detest them but at the same time we
had a wave of support from the local
population and that still continues
whenever and wherever these refugees
taxi also : tears there were volunteers
22 sorting supporting the refugees and
whenever there is a criminal attack on a
refugee camp or on a refugee as a person
then it will be persecuted by police and
by the persecutor and the law attorney
that is the state of law all right every
drive enjoy now let's talk a bit about
the Parliament voting last week to send
soldiers and hardware to support the
anti-isis coalition on the one hand the
Chancellor says it is perfectly clear
that the real solution can only lie in a
political solution if that's true
WAIS and hardware at all just for sure
no we have we have the refugee crisis
that can be solved only politically and
we have the Syrian crisis there are many
many actors on the ground applying
military force and making progress
whatever it is it is in the fight
against international terrorism and in
particular in the fight against the
Islamic states threatening Europe by
terrorist plots it is important that an
alliance of Western countries and
countries in the regions are fighting
those terrorists and that's exactly what
we are doing we are lending these are
this is a group this is a group that has
no ground strategy no exit strategy no
plan of campaign and is hopelessly
disunited look at the latest spat
between Turkey and Iraq for instance and
it hopelessly disunited but first of all
we have there are of course ground
troops ground troops FS for example the
Peshmerga in northern Iraq we have sent
weapons to them last year we are
organizing training for them since last
year they have been able to fight is
quite successfully in that region they
have is the American three months ago
says the fight was stalemated
round and and the second point is in
Syria in Syria we have seen that many of
the terrorist links to the terrorists of
Paris came from Syria where foreign
fighters where I as terrorists are
planning and plotting and therefore we
have decided to join the international
alliance and I believe it is the right
choice you're joining an alliance that
could last 10 years that the Americans
have already said is stalemated
in its fight against Isis this is this
is a terrorist group that has an address
people have been bombing it for almost
18 months and yet the fighters
stalemated
I don't I don't know it's not it's not a
winning formula that you're joining I
said it's not a winning coalition
on the contrary it's going on but nobody
nobody knows we have decided are very
opportunistic decided 14 years ago to
join the alliance in Afghanistan and we
have fought the Taliban quite successful
but we have not yet stabilized the
country as we would have wished for so
you think we are now joining we are now
joining this alliance it can get long
term because no it is it is first of all
it is confined to one year and then we
have to go to Parliament and we have to
ask Parliament whether to go on or
whether to stop this is the same by the
way for Afghanistan and that means we
are a keeping control of the entire
process at every moment and that's
exactly what the owed to all these
soldiers we are sending to Syria and to
the region and it's not the first for an
action that we are taking it is not the
biggest one but it is an important one
all right and I believe we have to be
successful and we can be success you're
a country that prides yourself on being
a moral state you care about human
rights but you trained extensively
despite heavy criticism from human
rights groups with Becka Stan which has
an appalling human rights record in
March you failed to do what Amnesty
International asked you to do which was
to demand that it was Becky Stan clears
up its human rights record on the
country you signed a 2.8 billion euro
trade package you part of your links
with this country we have links with
many countries across the world this
this is a normal situation in a
globalized world but whenever we are
doing politics we always insist on the
respect for human rights regardless
whether we are making deals with country
in Asia or in Africa or in will you see
that in this Germany is a country and
everybody knows that where we have
always been aware of the importance of
human rights but you know how they
torture people in Uzbekistan they
asphyxiate them
they rape they use electric shocks and
they pour boiling water over the naked
bodies of their victims and you tell me
no situation is true it is totally
unacceptable totally but it doesn't give
you any pause for thought in your trade
deals does it you're quite happy to go
and trade with them 2.8 billion euros
this year no this is this is totally
unjust what you are saying because we
are acting in coherence with the
international community and whenever so
the international everything that
scientists steal it's Germany when
Germany never sanction has been a blight
Germany has fully respected the
sanctions and then it's up to the
international community to decide
whether they would apply sanctions or
not and Saudi Arabia you're happy to do
there are the other largest recipient of
your weapons a new military hardware and
they have a palling human rights record
as well there are many other countries
worldwide there's a human record human
rights record is not perfect and we are
working to improve it wherever we can
but lesson first
as far as Saudi Arabia is concerned
there is a lot of criticism visibly
Saudi Arabia but it is a stabilizing
factor in the region where many
countries have collapsed and the record
is your intelligence is agree it will be
very it will be very difficult for you
to identify truly democratic states
where the rule of law is guaranteed and
the entire region of the Middle East
except Israel and one or two other
countries your own countries you can you
can identify problematic points and
whenever they are identified we are
trying to help the people but at the
same time international trade continuous
this is the same for the United Kingdom
for us for France for any other and the
case of Saudi Arabia in the case a Arab
your own intelligence service says it's
now pursuing impulsive interventionist
policies again does that give you pause
for thought
of course we are we have our
intelligence an agency exactly for the
purpose
to know what is going on in every
country but you'll trade anyway you
don't really give it any thought at all
do you
but I'm you're just gonna try now and
whatever the human I'm now I'm now I'm
now really really astonished a trade
embargo if it would apply trade
embargoes and sanctions to any country
the human rights are not fully respected
there would be almost no trade anymore
across the world Peter and I were gonna
leave it there thanks very much for
being on complex on thank you thank you